en combat maintenant passer au scanner
mission il ya beaucoup de rumeurs autour
d'avon de koh lanta même des fantasmes
je pense que mention on parle de tir
vous allez voir qu on a fait un petit
récap de ce qui se dit sur les missions
et en parle juste appelé ce soir c'est
le début de la vingtième saison de koh
lanta et comme tous les ans depuis le
début de cette grande aventure les mêmes
soupçons de trucage ou encore peser sur
la production les accusations constante
faite par la presse des anciens membres
de la prod et même des anciens candidats
alors de quoi le programme et il accusé
la principale accusatrice et elle a une
candidate de 2011 qui en a même fait un
livre intitulé la face cachée de mon koh
lanta selon elle la production donne de
la nourriture en douce aux candidats
nous ne pouvions en avoir naturellement
étant donné que ce n'était pas la belle
saison
la nature nous imposer ses propres
règles et il est difficile voire
impossible de les contourner sans un peu
triché elle balance aussi que la prod
les aides en cas de grosses intempéries
sur le camp la production a eu pitié de
nous elle accuse également les équipes
de production d'influencer les votes du
conseil en manipulant les candidats
juste avant
alors selon vous ces accusations sont
elles vraies et surtout décrédibilise
telle aventure koh lanta mais tombe bien
nous qui annonce forcément non pas que
alors premier secret est ce que oui ou
non on vous donne de la nourriture
la meilleure preuve c'est la différence
physique entre les candidats au début et
à la fin de l'ag kg chacun là on l'a
souligné osez le sentiment que depuis à
une ou deux saisons ils maigrissent un
peu moins qu'en mars et trouve que nous
sur le retour des héros on
il faut savoir que sur un retour
d'anciens candidats c'est plus court
déjà donc kg pour les femmes et 12 kg
pour les we environ est dans les bonnes
que savoure en 32 jours car un jour sur
le retour des héros avec d'anciens
candidats
les retours sont toujours un petit peu
plus petit peu plus court et donc on est
resté 32 jours au lieu de 42 donc
forcément on perd moins de quoi en tronc
de jours que 42 jours mais les
transformations je trouve censure
flagrante et moi en tout cas quand je
suis rentré vous dire j'ai voulu et vous
avez
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
premier jour j'ai assuré et abandonner
ma ma force physique sommes acquittées
j'ai fait des contre performances dans
les épreuves mais après c'est le mental
qui a pris le dessus pour justement
arriver jusqu'aux jean-mi pouvez vous
pouvez passer 50 jours au sein de l'état
pour faire vous permet je répondrai même
pas autre rumeur sur le feu on dit que
le feu soit il est donné sous il est
entretenu par la prod
soyez protéger quand il pleut ça le feu
il ya plusieurs saisons où le feu s'est
éteint parce qu'il ya des intempéries et
qui a des problèmes
après qui est ce qu'on peut se dire
c'est que quand par exemple il ya le
conseil
il faut blinder à fond le feu avant pour
que s'il ya une intempérie pendant le
conseil puisse rester valables dans ces
pays là quand ça se met à pleuvoir ça
c'est une bâche voilà donc on essaie de
le protéger au mieux de le
de le fournir aux plus quand on
s'éloigne du camp mais mais c'est
totalement faux autre rumeur on
interdirait aux candidats de faire date
et la télé réalité après koh lanta c'est
faux aussi on a la preuve aujourd'hui
notamment sur la dernière édition vous
via trois candidats qui sont déjà partis
sur des téléréalités donc ils ont une
totale liberté par rapport à ça et j'ai
envie de dire s'ils ont envie de le
faire il faut qu'ils le fassent et en
anglais gaza met en colère alexia
laroche-joubert y regarder on fait
qu'est-ce que je suis productrice mois
de télé réalité et donc j'adore le genre
de la terre a été après parce que en
plus c'était dommage c'est qu'ils le
savent je trouve que s'ils partent soit
autre chose qui est très incompatible
avec l'esprit de koh lanta voilà oui
mais c'est pas exhaustive wafa qui est
une des candidates elle était partie
faire une télé réalité sera sur nrj 12
n'a pas pu revenir alors que c'est une
grande aventure hier que c'est une femme
très très forte que j'admire beaucoup
donc je pense que ne tolère pas qu'ils
tolèrent qu'ils allaient faire des
téléréalités mais ensuite peuvent
parvenir doit être quand même façon par
métier koh lanta moi j'ai dit joubert
elle est très maternelle et c'est
quelqu'un qui est hyper bienveillante
avec ses pains avec ces personnalités je
pense que vous pouvez le dire et moi
m'avait expliqué un jour c'est pas
qu'ils aillent sans latéralité sait
jusqu'où elle les met à l'antenne et un
titre envie peut-être qu'ils lui en
parle pour qu'elle leur donne des
conseils etc
il ya des manières de faire quand ils
quittent des productions des fois qu'ils
sont un petit peu difficile à encaisser
pour les gens qui travaillent qui avance
avec eux tu na lire magali fois que
l'émission est terminée mais en soit ces
groupes
enfin je veux dire alp aussi dépend du
groupe banny g qui produit de télé
réalité comme moundir et c est comme le
dit clémence ils vont pour beaucoup dans
d'autres télé réalité pas revenir dans
koh lanta après non voilà ils ne peuvent
pas s'en mêler
j'ai une question essentielle qui me
vient est ce que la production fournie
du papier toilette avant de participer à
ma première édition
j'étais persuadé qu'ils auraient des
toilettes je me suis dit on la télé y
aura d'autres mais il n'y a rien du tout
il n'y a ni toilettes ni papier ni
brosse à dents ni rien à sa charge une
question la question un peu à peu fait
minime et qui me vient que se passe-t-il
si vous êtes indisposé par minute quand
on est une femme
franchement c'est une thalasso trois et
demi
dans koh lanta moi je m'y connais pas
enfin j'imagine j'imagine forcément les
éditions du dur tout plus d'un mois donc
oui devant randonnée voir notre on est
confronté à ça donc on a quand même à
notre disposition tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour faire au mieux